Samuel leads here hope you are good I
wanted to do a video today a little bit
about financial freedom and what that
means
I've been financially free now for six
years and my goal is to help a hundred
people become financially free I'm now
just sixteen people so I've got another
whole bunch to go what do I mean by
financial freedom well first let me just
bust some myths around financial freedom
and tell you what it is not so the first
thing that financial freedom is not is
it is not being super rich having
millions of pounds in the bank that's
not what I'm talking about when I say
financial freedom I did a survey with oh
there were over a hundred people and
asked them all what financial freedom
meant they came out with some very
interesting answer
some people said financial freedom means
not having to work no longer working if
you're out of a job then you are
financially free hmm so if you're
homeless and unemployed are you
financially free of course the answer is
no other people said having lots of
money in the bank means you're
financially free okay so you got a
million quid in the bank but you're
working a hundred hours a week at a
horrible corporate job that you hate are
you financially free of course not other
people say oh it's just doing what you
want when you want that's financial
freedom but that's very subjective what
does that mean exactly doing what you
want with who you want so the first
thing in order to work out what
financial freedom is I'm about to give
you my definition of what financial
freedom is but the first thing you need
to establish is the difference between
active income and passive income so once
you figure out this it's very easy to
them work out what financial freedom is
so active income is the income that
you're programmed to make when you're a
young child and you see your parents
working they go to work they get paid
effectively they trade their time for
money and that is active income now
passive income that is where you work
and you get paid forever so rather than
trading your time or money money is now
working for you that makes sense so what
are some examples of this
well active income some examples of
active income would be you're a Salesman
and every time you want to get paid
you've got to make a sale that's active
income or you've got a job where you go
to work and you get paid it's active
income passive income would be a
systemized business that functions and
runs without you and you're getting paid
but you're not actually doing anything
or maybe you've got a vending machine
business and you actually do anything
the vending machine takes care of itself
someone else stacks it up and you get
paid that's passive income the best way
and the best vehicle for passive income
in my opinion is property because you
buy the Hat how many times you have to
keep buying the house before the rent
starts and of course the answer is you
don't have to buy the house ever again
you buy the house once you get paid
again and again and again through rent
so I personally think property is the
best vehicle to passive income that
there is so when you figure out the
difference between passive income and
active income the definition to
financial freedom becomes super easy and
and that is this here's the definition
it's when your passive income or a money
that you get whether you work or not
when that is equal to or greater than
your living expenses you are financially
free yes the symbol as it is so let's
say cost cost you four thousand pounds a
month to live you know your bills your
house your mortgage payments your car
your clothes you're going out four grand
a month then to become financially free
you need four grand a month in passive
income and then you're free so that is
the definition of financial freedom you
can be financially free and you can live
a very normal life I really believe that
anybody can become financially free
within 12 months or less starting
anywhere I really believe that and I'm
on a mission I'm on a mission to create
a hundred people financially free by the
time I'm 30 years old so I've got a few
years left if you want that to be using
subscribe to this video check out more
video
I'll see you soon